something Allah peace be with you so I'm
like oh and thank you for tuning in to
the Deen show Ramadan is here and you
want to know why are you fasting people
want to know about Ramadan so a lot of
the not yet Muslims are tuning in all
this and more you're gonna learn about
what Ramadan why are the Muslims fasting
why are you fasting some people don't
even know why they fasted so we're gonna
be talking about why you're fasting who
your fasted for and also the many
tremendous benefits of fasting all of
this and more here on the D show my next
guest coming up don't go anywhere
Salam alaikum peace be with you
Malik oh my soul our him delight with
doctor to me or how are you we made it
to the blessed month of Ramadan and now
we're trying to educate people and it's
really important nowadays many people
not just a not yet Muslims but even the
Muslims they many don't know why they're
fasting you know the significance of it
and the benefits of it so we only wanna
you know a kind of an ABC approach
really simplify it so people can really
get into the spirit of Ramadan when they
know what it's all about
good good hand Allah well first and
foremost I would like to say as salam
aliekum wa rahamtullah Heba Barakat the
who to all the viewers up there it's
very important that any act or any
interaction any worse that a Muslim or
anyone should be saying we should be
connecting with the Creator so all
throughout the centuries our Creator has
given a certain Commandments starting
with Prophet Adam peace be upon him then
new-ha Abraham Moses Jesus peace be upon
all of them our Creator has sent the
commandment the fundamental commandment
is that we should be worshipping the
Creator alone and not the creation so in
that
text our Creator has given the
injunction of fasting so it says in the
Quran chapter number 2 verse number 183
that oh you who believe fasting has been
given to you as it was given to those
before you that you may obtain God
consciousness and sub-discipline so the
reason that we Muslims are fasting first
and foremost is because we are being the
Creator and it also says that other
people before us they were given the
same injunction of fasting so fasting we
are doing it because obviously it gives
us that self-discipline God
consciousness and ultimately the reward
by the Creator inshallah God willing now
you said in every word when you say
Muslim do you are you referring to any
conscious person human being peaceful
human being who submits to the crater is
this what what you mean when you say
Muslim because some people say Muslim oh
those are those terrorists over there
but what do you mean when you say Muslim
yeah the word Muslim it means someone
who actively consciously submits to the
one creator says that I am only going to
believe in you God you are the only
creator you are one and I submit to your
commandments and I make an intention to
obey your commandments that is the
definition of a Muslim so we can we can
clearly say without a shadow of doubt
that Jesus was a Muslim is that right
yes Jesus was a Muslim because it says
in the Quran chapter number 3 verse
number 51 that so Jesus Christ has been
quoted in the Quran he's saying that God
is my lord and he's your Lord worship
Him alone and that is the straight path
so we know that Jesus was a pure
monotheistic Muslims he was a Muslim he
called to the worship of the crater
another Christian he prayed we prayed
the same way putting our head to the
ground and he fasted so he did the fast
to the same thing is this the same
tradition that we're seeing here yes
it's very important that when we look at
the previous prophets who came before
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him they
all used to worship the one creator and
they used to call people to worship the
one creator for example
it says in the Old Testament in the book
of Genesis chapter 17 verse number 3
that Abraham peace be upon him prophet
ibrahim alaih-is-salaam when the time of
prayer came he used to go to a nice
quiet place and worship the one creator
by bowing himself down on his forehead
the way that Muslims are praying Moses
peace be upon him it says the same thing
in the book of Exodus chapter 40 verse
number 3 putting his forehead on the
ground he used to worship the one
creator what is the first commandment
brother Eddie the Inca the Old Testament
that's the same thing thou shalt worship
know the God's up to one God that's it
now to stick not a stone at a man here
always were the guy that LORD thy God is
one so worshiping God alone that's
that's the first command with all your
heart your mind
yes yes so prophet Moses peace be upon
him when he was given according to the
Bible the Ten Commandments the very
first commandment according to the book
of Exodus chapter 20 verse number three
that there is only one God he should not
take any other God before me and he
should not make any graven images of God
that was prophet Moses proclaimed to his
people though you'll be amazed to find
out that prophet Jesus peace be upon him
when people asked him this very
fundamental question that of all the
commandments which one is the first and
the biggest one it says in the Gospel of
Mark chapter number 20 chapter number 12
verse number 29 but Jesus Christ he
mentioned here o Israel the Lord our God
he is one worshiping with all your heart
all your mind all your soul all your
strength and that is the first
commandment so it's very important that
we muslims when we are fasting and
praying and worshipping the creator
we're not doing just in isolation just
because prophet muhammad peace be upon
him brought those commandments by the
Creator we are doing it because we are
connecting with all the prophets and
messengers because all of them they used
to worship the one creator they used to
pray the same way that muslims are
praying and they used to fast the way
that muslims are fasting maybe I could
give you a couple of reference about
fasting in the old in the New Testament
yeah before we go to break give us
one of those before we go to great great
wonderful when prophet Moses peace be
upon him when he received the Ten
Commandments he was in the state of
fasting so it says in the book of Exodus
chapter 20 verse number three that Moses
was fasting number two Jesus Christ
peace be upon him Matthew chapter 4
verse number 2 he was fasting for about
forty days and forty nights and we
Muslims when we are fasting
we are following not only the ideology
of oneness of God that all the prophets
used to believe and call people to we
are also following the rituals of all
the prophets and messengers same
tradition same way of life nothing
different yeah because it says in the
Quran chapter 42 verse number 13 in the
Quran which we Muslims say this is the
last and the final revelation coming
from the Creator chapter 42 verse number
13 it says the the same Deen the same
way of life given to you Muhammad peace
be upon him it also was also given to
Prophet Noah Abraham Moses and Jesus
peace be upon him because that would
make sense if all of them came with
different religions one humanity one
universal religion since the beginning
of time and has been submission to the
will of God
that's Islam that is Islam there's the
definition so mission to the Creator
that's it so we got that out of the way
we fast because it's a command from the
creator right we're gonna talk about the
benefits when we come back and much more
it's the same tradition Moses Abraham
Jesus all of them Mohammed being the
last final message they all pray to God
the Creator they didn't worship the
creation they prayed they fasted and did
all these wonderful things that we're
doing right back with more here in
Ramadhan is here's when we talking more
about it on the Deen she'll be right
back
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you bismillah
alhamdulillah Salaam aleikum peace be
unto us mullah al hamdulillah Salaam
alaikum bismillah alhamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be unto you welcome to the
Dean shop bismillah alhamdulillah Salaam
alaikum peace be with you greetings of
peace to everybody all around the globe
has tuning in to the Deen shop
back here on the D show and we're into
Ramadan we're talking about it's one of
the pillars of Islam
obviously Islam's based on five pillars
one to worship nothing but the Creator
your maker and to accept all the
messengers Muhammad being the last Jesus
being one of those and Abraham Moses are
the ones that we mentioned praying five
times a day then we have the Ramadan
fasting during the month of Ramadan
we're talking about that and this is new
to a lot of people so some people are
like you know we know and obesity is on
the rise people are dying from
overeating so now here we come and we're
saying God is saying actually look you
have to refrain from food and this will
help you one of the benefits is to
become more conscious God conscious and
to develop self-discipline so you know
people are like okay what do i do do I
just refrain from eating all day how can
I you know people are in love with food
you know we you know it's not necessary
bad thing but overindulging so how can
we explain this is that's what it's all
about you're gonna I'm just gonna give
up food and is that gonna improve my
character what's what what more goes
into this fasting talk to us okay so
wonderful Ramadan is the name of the
ninth month of the Islamic lunar
calendar so in that month Muslims are
supposed to fast for the whole month but
it's not a 24-hour day fasting by the
way that may be next to impossible so we
thought we fast from dawn to sunset so
nowadays because there's summertime it
is about 17 hours of fasting so before
we start the first we wake up before
dawn we eat a light meal and then we
fast the whole day we don't eat anything
we don't drink anything not even a
single drop of water and then at sunset
then we break the fast so fasting is not
just about not eating or not drinking or
not having intimate relationship with
our spouses fasting is also developing
that God consciousness the closeness to
God so enhancing our spirituality our
piety that means during the state of
fasting we should be overly conscious
it's like a mini boot camp by the way we
should be overly conscious of doing all
the good things that we should be doing
throughout the year having connection
with God reading more Quran pondering on
it implementing it sharing it number one
number two we should be looking at the
society and trying to enhance the
society that means if there is a someone
in the society that needs help like the
poor people who are deprived we are
supposed to reach out to them one in
sharing the soup kitchens for example
and all the wonderful things that we are
supposed to do we are supposed to keep
on doing it extra in the month of
fasting thirdly very important all the
bad things that we were not supposed to
do anyway we should be overly conscious
in eradicating them examples some people
they still smoke right cigarettes so in
the month of Ramadan we should be
obviously prohibiting it on ourselves
because there's not good in Islam also
prohibit said by the way anything that
harms our body backbiting for example
you know unconsciously sometimes we do
backbiting we're supposed to be overly
conscious and avoiding it
some people they lie they may cheat they
may not honor their parents the way that
they should so all the good things we
should inculcate and all the bad things
we should eradicate so for this whole
month like a boot camp if we are
conscious in that way inshallah God
willing after we are done with the 30
days of fasting that will become our
second nature and this is known I mean
as a characteristic of human traits that
you can go ahead and make something a
habit for three weeks plus yeah you know
rather it be a good or bad you know so
stick with you but you know if you drop
bad habits like for instance you know we
know God is the most merciful and loving
but now you had a bad hat you you were
doing a you know something that was
prohibited for instance like you said
smoking or drinking alcohol and now you
refrain for it from it for a whole month
and you prove that you can do it you
don't to go back to it now do you so it
becomes part of our second nature you
know for example suppose at our place of
employment
our boss tells us you know for your
training go three weeks of training in
California and for all day from 9:00
aim to 5:00 p.m. you would be part of
your training for three weeks now to
please our boss we do it because we want
the check at the end of the day likewise
we want to please our Creator who has
given us all these wonderful things so
when we are fasting once we have that
you know we are fasting for the Creator
that ultimately the reward is going to
be given to us by the Creator fasting
becomes a little bit more easier for us
to inculcate all the good things that we
are supposed to do the way the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him the charity
that he used to do enhancing the society
and refraining from all the bad things
yeah so we see Lada that will get into a
lot of the health benefits you know
science is making these discoveries now
that we've already been told from the
wisdom of the creator and we have it
here but we see like we're refraining
from things that are legal eating food
and relations with your spouse during
the day so this is also a proof now if
you can give this up you're strong
enough to give this up for 30 days
obviously at the end this training camp
you know you can come out stronger and
beget be a better develop yourself to be
the best human being rise to the
occasion rise to your full potential
exactly exactly you know I mean I mean
we are all human beings we are fallible
human beings when it comes to our diet I
mean one in three people in USA maybe
some other countries too they're obese
you know when we are driving we may have
a bag of chips next to us when we are at
work we may have a hick box of candies
next to us right so we are overly
indulging in all of these habits so when
we are fasting we are refraining from
things which may be halal or which may
be permitted which which may be
permissible that means when we are
fasting that means when we are staying
away from these it is easier for us to
stay away from things that you're not
supposed to be eating anyway or doing
anyway so it's say if I have to say in
one word it would be solve discipline
big time yeah yeah before we go to break
also I mean if you're lying deceiving
cheating backbiting God doesn't need
your fast does he no because it will it
will be just we are hungry
it will not be you know it will not be
accepted so it's very important there is
not just about not eating not drinking
or not having all of this relationship
it's about being overly conscious of
avoiding the bad things and in an
inculcating all the wonderful things
yeah let's take beautiful masha'Allah
let's take a break and we right back
with more time our Ramadan it's here
we're gonna be talking about it and ask
you some more questions we're gonna be
also Tama the benefits there's
scientific discoveries and who else who
knows best our Creator and we're doing
the best thing by following what our
craters told us to do we're gonna get in
some of these benefits of fasting when
we come back here on a Deen show you
when I embrace the slam from that day on
I knew I never wanted to drink another
drink in my life I never wanted a smoke
I never wanted to harm my body because I
realized that it was a blessing you know
to be able to see life from the
perspective of Islam because it's like a
lens that clarifies life for you and so
I started seeing the clarity of life and
I said this is what I've been looking
for all my life now all I have to do is
live up to it
you
back here on the D show Ramadan we're
talking about it helping educate the
not-yet Muslims and the Muslims many
turned us into let's say a yearly ritual
and we want to get people into the
spirit of Ramadan to really know why
you're doing it so when you know why
you're doing it that you're doing it for
your Creator we talked about that this
is nothing new Islam is not a new
religion brought by Mohammed it's the
same way of life that was practiced by
all the prophets including Jesus Abraham
all of them they weren't Christian they
were or any other religion they were
Muslims they were doing Islam so now
this also helps to give us confidence in
our Islam in what we're doing and some
people now they even get more inspired
when they see like wow these doctors
medical professionals scientists are
discovering that fasting it actually has
tremendous health benefits for you
you're actually a medical doctor
yourself aren't you right so by
education I'm a medical doctor yes so
yeah can we get into some of these
health yes/no so before I speak about
the health benefits of fasting there's a
footnote I would like to mention right
away so Muslims are not resting because
of the health benefits by the way health
benefits are like a bonus for us like an
add-on
yeah our Creator has given to us but the
first and foremost reason is that God
told us to fast and we are fasting
absolutely and alhamdulillah all praise
praise be to Allah
health benefits so from the health point
of view there have been many many
research that has been done natural
health system of UK they have done a
very humongous research and according to
them they found out that from for our
whole body from all the organs which are
involved in fasting how much enhance
that they are from the medical point of
view for example when we are fasting we
initially use the glucose the sugar
which is stored in the liver
once that is used then what is used are
the fats and some of us has more fair
than others right so fat is born as
energy and when fat is
this energy that means a person
eventually lose weight and eventually
that will have a very enhance you know
situation for the body about reducing
the cholesterol so the bad cholesterol
which is there in the body it goes away
or it is reduced and the goods good
cholesterol which is called as the HDL
it increases so that itself prevents
many hard conditions many conditions
like stroke many conditions like
diabetes yes so all of those benefits
are there because of fasting now it's
very important for the viewers to know
that when Muslims when we start the fast
and when we break the fast we do it with
the date fruit right mm-hmm it's very
delicious by the way if you have not yet
eaten it go ahead if you want to take a
sample of that it's very important when
we break the fast with the date fruit it
has vitamins and minerals and it has
fructose and dextrose in it so I'll try
for them so how's that bismillah this
might go ahead hmm good stuff yeah
delicious so not only it is delicious by
the way much delicious that then the
Mars candy and the sneaker candy it has
nutrients it has minerals which is good
for a bot of a body near step number one
number two it has fibers in there so it
acts as a very good laxative number two
number three
whenever colon is clean that means it
has less effect of building up of all
the the herb of all the toxins which are
accumulating in in our body all
throughout the year so when we are
fasting when we are eating the date
fruit and we are conscious of all the
health benefits our cholesterol comes
down our health increases and this is
just as an add-on effect for us
alhamdulillah I'm gonna take you to a
clip of what also doctors medical
practitioners are saying rope and in
this one clip real quick they can see it
people who do that have a lower risk of
diabetes and also coronary artery
disease okay and we've gone on a recent
study that we've
completed that is being published this
year in an academic medical journal we
found that asking people to fast we
found that there are a number of
metabolic changes in their bodies that
were unexpected and that potentially
have prolonged effects due to thousand
fat cells in the body and renewing the
the insulin the the sensitivity to
insulin human growth hormone went up
substantially which has potential it's
an antagonist to insulin which are the
that's the process that insulin becomes
body becomes resistant to insulin I just
got to hear this from a medical
professional and talking about pretty
much the same thing you're talking about
so this is not this is this is not just
Muslim saying is these are people out
there who've done the research and
they're seeing that fasting actually it
makes sense your body's always working
hard to digest all this food and now you
give it time to break and rebuild itself
replenish yourself rejuvenate itself and
we come out winners at the end all right
so any which way that we look at this we
are pleasing our Creator because we are
listening to his Commandments number one
number two when we are fasting we are
more conscious of the people who are
less fortunate than us so we reach out
to them and we enhance the society
number three very important the health
benefits but you're not fasting for the
health benefits but any it's very
important that in the month of Ramadan
the Quran was revealed also by the way
so Quran is the book that is a guidance
for humanity as it says in the Quran
chapter 2 verse number 185 that in the
month of Ramadan the Quran was revealed
as the guidance for humanity and as a
criteria to differentiate between right
and wrong so Quran provides who is the
Creator
it tells us number two it also notifies
the purpose of life that is we should
worship the Creator alone and not the
creation in the most holistic way number
three it gives us the guidance and
solutions for humanity's problems very
important and number four very very
important
a wave for salvation it says in the
Quran chapter 2 verse number 25 anyone
who has the right belief and do good
deeds God's mercy comes into play and
insha'Allah God willing eternal paradise
so Ramadhan is not just about fasting it
is about this wonderful guidance that
our Creator has given to us so we could
be the best in this world and obtain
eternal paradise in the hereafter in sha
allah masha allah may we strive to obey
our Creator and to achieve ultimate
success because what other better place
to end up then Jenna paradise by living
this short life in a way that's pleasing
to the one who made you the one you're
going to return back to exactly Ramadan
right now is is one of the best ways to
achieve that isn't it there's the best
way to achieve it so I also pray that
all of us and all the people who are
watching that may God gives us the
motivation inspiration the guidance so
all of us not only just follow what is
in the Quran but if we also follow the
message of all the prophets and
messengers which is absolute oneness of
the Creator worship the Creator and not
the creation so a very small way that I
usually mentioned to my Christian and
the Jewish and other friends would be if
you love Jesus and Moses peace be upon
them follow their faith their faith was
Islam absolute submission to one God if
you love them pray the way that they
used to pray they used to pray by
putting the forehead on the ground the
way that Muslims are praying if you love
them fast the way that you use that they
used to fast and the way that Muslims
are fasting now so if you embrace all of
this you're embracing the oneness of God
and all the prophets
masha'Allah that's right thank you very
much peace be with you and we look to
have you back again sometime in the
future have a blessed Ramadan thank you
so glad and thank you for tuning in may
the Creator that happens in the earth
wish you a blessed Ramadan enjoy the
Ramadan use it to connect with Allah the
Creator through the Quran the verbatim
word of God he
sent it as a mercy for you so connect it
read it try to get through it through
this mantra my dad and try not to go
back now if we can make these bad habits
go away during Ramadan and pick up new
good ones that's the idea to give
refresh for the rest of the year so if
you are coming into Ramadan smoking
which is something prohibited drinking
alcohol gambling and all these other
things and you did it for the crater you
left it alone and you prove that you can
do it for a whole month leave it alone
now don't go back to it and let's try
not to over indulge at the same time so
the problem peace be upon him said the
believer eats with one intensity with
one stomach not seven so let's try to
make sure that when the time for fast
when it's over that we don't over
indulge because all of the bad things
come from filling this stomach and all
the diseases with overeating all the
processed foods and try to eat healthy
try to keep a good diet going and try to
really so we can get up in the night so
we can pray and we can really get the
most out of this blessed month of
Ramadan thank you for tuning in make
sure to follow us on the Twitter on the
Facebook subscribe to our YouTube
channel and contribute towards the Deen
show so we can help continue to run this
helped take it to the next level we'll
see you next time
until then peace be unto you so support
the Dawa support the Deen show
contribute and help us spread this
message this message of peace peace
acquired by submission to the will of
God Islam we'll see you next time tune
in every week to the D show follow us on
the Twitter and the Facebook squad
subscribe to our YouTube channels and
wherever you're watching us continue to
watch the same time same channel peace
be unto you a Salam aleikum